hi I'm Patrick Bailey with your host of
value taming weekly and today's question
is who is a better money manager the
private sector and corporations or the
public sector and the government
so a lot of times the media takes shots
at companies for how little taxes they
pay and I figured why not share with you
how much tax is the ten biggest
companies in America paid to the US
government in taxes number ten and this
and these are numbers according to
Forbes 2012 numbers number ten happens
to be Microsoft they paid roughly 4.6
billion dollars in taxes to the
government in 2012 IBM paid 5.3
Berkshire Hathaway paid 6.9 JP Morgan
Chase paid seven point six billion
ConocoPhillips Philips paid seven point
nine Walmart eight billion Wells Fargo
nine point 1 billion Apple fourteen
point two 1 billion Chevron 20 billion
Exxon Mobil 31 billion dollars in 2012
in taxes so so that's a lot of text as
some of you may say I never thought they
would have paid down much taxes that's a
lot of taxes they pay every year to the
US government and the question I asked
earlier is who is better at managing the
money because every time you and I vote
to raise taxes whatever the new program
may be we're gonna come with our health
care program we're gonna do this and
it's gotta be free it's never free
because we pay for the money only comes
from you and I taxes going back to them
if we vote for taxes to go higher what
we're voting for is the fact that the
government is better at managing money
than we are obviously the government's
got a place with military public school
in certain areas but not an everyday
life of everything we do so let me give
you an example of a company I want you
to think about this restaurant we can
call it XYZ company it's similar to
Chili's Olive Garden and similar to
Applebee's type of a restaurant where it
costs them roughly 1 million dollars to
open up each restaurant and each
restaurant that they open up employs
roughly 50 employees part-time full-time
50 total employees and let's just say in
2012 their net revenues was roughly 1
billion dollars is what they were their
net revenues after everything their net
was 1 billion and they have to pay
roughly 33 percent taxes on that 1
billion dollars which is 330 million
dollars they would pay in taxes which
that goes to the government 330 million
dollars and
taxes I want to pose the question what
would happen if we were to keep that 330
million dollars in XYZ corporations
money instead of that money goes to the
government let's just kind of take a
look at what if this were to happen if
that money was to be kept in X Y Z's
company what would they do with the
money many times we think they're gonna
go buy Lamborghinis or you know big
diamond necklaces that's got corporation
on there or free enterprise under
they're gonna take that money and
reinvest the money's what they typically
do so if this company takes that three
hundred thirty million dollars and they
said we can expand and let's open up
three hundred and thirty new restaurants
if they were to take that three hundred
and thirty million dollars that they
were going to paint taxes now they don't
and they open up three hundred thirty
restaurants it's 1 million per
restaurant that's three hundred thirty
restaurants times 50 jobs per restaurant
which is roughly sixteen thousand seven
hundred fifty new jobs created in the
economy of people making salaries and
typically full-time employees yet health
benefits say fifty percent is health
benefits that's eight thousand three
hundred and seventy-five people that now
have health benefits health insurance
provided to them through the corporation
free enterprise private sector and then
let's look at the number of the number
of employees we have sixteen thousand
seven hundred fifty employees each if
they were to make roughly twenty
thousand dollars an average of annual
salary take the lowest person part-time
extent grand the supervisor makes a
hundred thousand let's just take twenty
thousand dollars on average if you take
sixteen thousand seven hundred fifty
employees multiplied times twenty
thousand you know what number you get
you get three hundred and thirty five
million dollars of revenues generated
through the employees and jobs created
and if we were to say those employees
pay thirty percent in taxes take the
regular taxes they pay federal state and
the sales tax that's still going to
taxes regardless right if added or three
thirty five thirty percent is taxes
that's a 100 million dollars of revenues
going back into the government so you
may ask the question and said well wait
a minute Patrick three hundred and
thirty million to the government is a
lot more than a hundred million dollars
to the government no problem let's
subtract the numbers so we know what
we're really working
with 3:30 - 100 million leaves us with
what 230 million so the question becomes
that 230 million dollars in the private
sector generated sixteen thousand seven
hundred fifty jobs potentially and
eighty four hundred people on health
care on health insurance from private
sector and three hundred thirty new
restaurants in new shopping centers that
brings traffic that helps other
surrounding businesses who are local to
them as well could the government gotten
the same exact type of results with that
two hundred thirty million dollars of
creating that many jobs in that kind of
traffic you need to answer that question
with the way you vote for taxes we
determine what you think will generate
more jobs so now here's the thing the
difference is this you may say well you
know what Patrick all the corporations
are not going to take their money and do
this and do that and it's not a perfect
world in the corporate world and there's
no way they're gonna do and the numbers
not gonna work out this way look you
know how you and I vote for businesses
we vote through the way we spent our
money if we don't like coffee bean
because they are changing certain things
where do we go to we go to Starbucks if
you don't like Burger King you'll go to
McDonald's if you don't like Quiznos you
go to Subway you don't like Chevrolet
you'll go to Ford but we have a choice
through free enterprise because the
thing that makes free-market capitalism
free enterprise were prevents monopolies
there's always competition the biggest
monopolies that we really have as a
government because when it comes down to
the government on how we pay our tab
that's the part that there is no choice
on this side there is a choice on the
other side there isn't a choice because
here's a question for you did you have a
say in any of these things that the
government spend money on and how do you
feel about the way the government spend
money on these things
Department of Health and Human Services
plans to spend five hundred million
dollars on a program that will seek to
solve the problem of five-year-old
children that can't sit still in a
kindergarten classroom wait a minute
five hundred million dollars to find out
why five-year-old can't sit still I
don't care if we spend a trillion
dollars do you really think we can make
a five-year-old sit still I don't know
about that here's another one the
federal government once spent thirty
million dollars on a program that was
designed to help Pakistani farmers
produce more mangoes look I like mango
just as much as the other person I love
the mango juice I can get a Jamba Juice
but you know what I like more I like
more Americans having jobs than us
having more mangoes in Pakistan I think
that's what's more important to you and
I then mangos in Pakistan the federal
government spent twenty five billion
dollars every single year maintaining
federal buildings that are either unused
or totally vacant let me ask you a
question
what would happen if those buildings
were you were owned by private companies
you know what they would have done one
of two things they're even gonna sell it
to somebody else that'll put it to use
or number two they're gonna do what
lease it to somebody that'll put it to
use but there's no way they're gonna
spend twenty five billion dollars you
know wasting their money you and I we're
paying for that ourselves US farmers are
given a total of two billion dollars
each year to not farm their land does
that make any sense I'm a farmer you
giving me money to not farm my land and
you know who's given a two billion you
and I are so my message today is very
simple all I'm encouraging you to do is
the next time it comes for you and I to
vote for a program that's going to raise
taxes all you and I are doing when we
vote that way is we're saying the
government is better at managing our
money by giving them taxes than free
market or free enterprises and the
private sector is that's all we're
saying but what I'd like to see more
probably just like yourself I want to
see more jobs in our economy I mean too
many people that don't have jobs that
are good people wanting to take care of
their wife and kids they need more jobs
and history has proven to us over and
over and over again private sector is
the best at producing jobs for people
the best and I've worked for government
and I've worked at private sector and
I've owned my own business private
sector is the best at producing jobs
it's my message in a week to you and
please be sure to subscribe and share
this video
you